-Our next guest
is a talented actress
you know from her work in shows
such as "The Knick"
and "Bad Sisters."
She stars in the film
"Flora and Son,"
which is streaming now
on Apple TV+.
Let's take a look.
-I do intend to learn the
guitar and take it seriously.
Why? I don't know.
I was always the one in class
making fun of the teacher
because someone had to.
But I won't if you'll
keep teaching me.
Sorry I objectified you.
I can send you a picture
of my amazing tits
to balance things out again,
if you'd like.
Flora.
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
[ Cellphone swishes ]
Right. Now let's get
that [bleep] off your arse.
-Please welcome back to the show
Eve Hewson, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back.
-Thank you. It's so good to be
here, finally.
-It's a thrill to have you.
You -- This is a wonderful film
about a young mother
who connects with a troubled son
by learning to play guitar
and singing music.
I've heard you are afraid
of singing in public.
-Terrified.
-Always.
-This is not for me.
This was not my plan
in life to sing.
-But you can sing.
-No, I...
I can, like...
♪ Eeh-dee-dee-dee-dee-dee ♪
-Okay, so I take it back.
You can't, yeah.
-I sound --
I think, in the film,
I sound like
a tiny baby chipmunk
with, like,
a dagger at its back,
like, "Sing, sing."
And I'm like...
[ Vocalizes ]
-But, now, do the other people
feel like you sound that way
or do you think
that's only through your ears?
-I read a review where they
said I sang like an angel.
-Oh!
-And I sent it immediately
to my singing teacher.
-Oh, that's good.
-I was like, "What did we do?
How did this happen?"
-The singing teacher was like,
"I am going to put that
on my business card."
-Absolutely. He's -- Yeah.
-So, but you actually --
This is a very real fear.
There were times in your career
where if you had to sing
in an audition,
you would just --
-I would leave.
-You would just beat it.
-Anytime I'd read a script
and the the character
would start singing,
I was like, "Ooh, sorry.
Can't do it. You know, busy."
-Nothing must have been worse
than if you read
a whole screenplay,
and only at the very end
did your character sing,
and you were like --
-That's how I felt
actually reading this script,
because it was so funny
and it was so good.
And I was like, "Please
no singing, please no singing."
And then I got halfway through
and I was like, "Oh, God!"
No, but I had --
I auditioned for "La La Land,"
which everybody knows
"La La Land."
-Came this close to winning
the Oscar.
-It did.
And thank God
I'm not in it, you know?
But, basically, I went in,
and they were like,
"Okay, so, you're meeting
with Damien Chazelle,
and it's kind of
an improv-y thing."
And I was like, "Oh, improv.
Fine. Like, I'll go in.
I like that stuff."
So, I go in -- joke, joke, joke,
charm, charm, charm.
And Damien is like, "Ha ha ha."
And I leave.
And my agent calls me
and she's like,
"Oh, my God, he loves you.
He thinks you're great.
And you have to go back in now
for your second audition.
It's the singing."
And I was like, "No."
-You big-timed him.
-I literally was like,
"I'm absolutely not going.
Like, there's nothing
you could say."
And they were like,
"This could be an Oscar movie.
It's very big for your career."
I was like, "Absolutely not
going to happen."
-That must be so funny
as an agent to, like,
hang up the phone and be like,
"I think we have
a terrible client."
-I know. She was
so frustrated with me.
And I also wasn't getting a lot
of work at the time either,
so it was like --
-I like that you stood
on ceremony there
and I like that it worked out.
I also -- I have to say,
"Bad Sisters"
was one of my favorite shows
of recent years.
-Thank you. Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah!
Like this film,
it took place in Dublin.
And I wanted to ask,
because there's sort of
a big part of the film
is that everybody --
-Yes.
-What is it called, again?
-It's called the Forty Foot.
-The Forty Foot.
And it's sort of jumping off
into the water.
And had you ever done it as a --
-Yeah, I grew up five minutes
away from there.
-And so you had
actually done it before?
-I had done it before,
but I sort of --
To prep for the show,
I was doing it every day.
-Gotcha.
-And --
-To prep for the fear
of jumping off?
What's the worst part --
-No, you have to get
your body temperature
into a certain place
or else you'll die.
-Gotcha.
-Yeah.
-That's great.
-And it was funny
because the other --
-That's why
a lot of people don't take
spring-break trips to Dublin.
-Yeah.
-They should.
-They should, yeah.
-The other girls were like,
"I just don't think
this is going to be safe
and I don't think
we should do it."
I was like,
"Guys, the whole show
is based around this location."
-Yeah, it culminates with
this moment, yeah.
-We have to do it.
So, when we got there,
they were like,
"Oh, no, you're just going to
jump off the steps."
And I was like, "I've been
practicing jumping off
the cliff.
I must do the cliff."
So I did the cliff.
-And did the rest of your cast
do the cliff?
-Nope.
-Yeah.
Well, I'm glad
we made it very clear here
that that was all stunt doubles
except for you.
You were the real deal.
You received --
Early in your career,
you've worked
with some great actors.
You received
-Oh, gosh.
-From one of my favorite actors,
you received a note
about something you did well,
that you've continued
to do well.
So, this is the original, yes?
-There I am.
-Okay. And who was the actor?
-I worked -- One of
the first movies I did,
I was 20 years old and I played
James Gandolfini's daughter.
-The great James Gandolfini.
-In "Enough Said."
And we did a scene --
Myself, James Gandolfini,
and Julia Louis-Dreyfus.
And we were eating lunch,
and I just demolished the salad.
in every take.
And afterwards, he was like,
"This is the greatest
acting I've ever seen."
You know, coming from the king
of eating on camera.
He invented it.
-Yes, I was gonna say.
The great eating actor
of our time.
-So, he was like, "I love you.
You're the best.
I hate seeing these actors.
They're..."
And so he was like,
"Keep doing that."
-And you have.
-I have every time,
in every movie.
As a tribute to Jim.
-There you go. Just everywhere.
Just chowing down.
-All the time.
And it is a tribute to Jim, but
very quickly, like, there --
-I'm also hungry,
but it's also a tribute to Jim.
-But there are,
of course, people on set
who probably would prefer you
to do the tiny nibble.
-Yeah, the props department
were like, "Oh, my God.
Here we go."
And even when we were
shooting "Flora,"
John Carney, our director,
was like, "Oh, my God.
You're really eating
that spaghetti."
I was like, "Of course I am."
-I love it.
They're like -- Like, both
props and budget is like,
"We are over our
spaghetti budget.
-I know.
-"We can't afford this."
-"We can't hire Eve Hewson.
The spaghetti budget
goes way up."
-She won't sing and she eats
all the spaghetti.
Congratulations
on this beautiful film.
And it's so lovely
to see you again.
Thanks for being here.
-Thank you so much.
-Eve Hewson, everybody.
"Flora and Son" is streaming
now on Apple TV+.
We'll be right back
with Ari Melber.